hey guys it is August the 26th today my
name is Jess and he's the things that
mattered in gaming the beta for call of
duty black ops 3 landed on PC and Xbox
one today after debuting on ps4 last
week well it tried to land its suckling
while PC users appear to be doing okay
an Xbox Live service alert acknowledge
issues with Xbox one beta code
redemption microsoft said they're
working with activision to get the
problem fixed ASAP adding will post
another update when more information
becomes available currently the beta is
only available to people who pre-ordered
the game and it's due to run until
August 30 Google's video game focused
live streaming service YouTube gaming
launched today and here's everything you
need to know about it the Google
overlords of YouTube have made the
service available on the web and as an
app it currently has over 25,000
dedicated game pages and it hosts live
streams as well as aggregating game
related youtube videos users can add
specific games to a collection to stay
up to date with new content or they can
subscribe to specific users and channels
to receive notifications of new videos
and when livestream start how well the
service will perform against the
streaming giant twitch remains to be
seen fans of dinosaurs are in for a
treat today as it's been announced that
90s first-person shooter games turak and
turok 2rg to get Ringmaster's chirac
dinosaur hunter and truck to seeds of
evil are getting a makeover from pc
restoration company night dive studios
the studio have said both games will
receive enhanced graphics as well as
other improvement adding when turok
dinosaur hunter was first released it
was nothing short of revolutionary to
that point no game has ever offered the
combination of graphics and an open
world environment that turok featured
night dive has previously remastered PC
classics including system shock 2 and
Sid Meier's corners
station your release dates have been
revealed as yet let me know down in the
comments if you think youtube gaming
look pull people away from twitch or not
and why you can add a game spot where
we've got news on which are three sales
and our review for doubles third that is
everything i have for you today be sure
to leave me your thoughts down in that
comment section and i will catch you
again tomorrow